a few centimeters of Steel remain on the
side they have to be removed before the
ALS leaves the dock the ship's huge
crane has to be laid on its side before
it weighs anchor the 100 meter long
crane is one of the highlights for
project director Oliver Arnold
the kindness of cabal teen born of the
crane is built like a donut in the
middle that gives us a lot of room on
the work deck to put the wind power
units after learning tool lets you out
at sea the ship has to be stable almost
like a platform to achieve this it
relies on both high-performance
technology and a clever structural
design environmental conditions don't
force us to interrupt the installation
process if the weather gets bad we can
simply jack it up a bit higher to gain
more distance between the water in the
body of the ship it's a groundbreaking
vessel but there haven't been any
follow-up orders due to the continued
uncertainty in the offshore sector in
2011 the shipyard had to declare
bankruptcy and lay off workers send a
yin moon at vinegar give we were losing
20 to 30 workers each month that's of
course quite unsettling nobody knew if
they would be affected by the layoffs
there was always stress at the end of
the month and then we could work for
another four weeks Albuquerque just days
before the ship was to be delivered
Arnold and his team received news that
the shipyard had been sold likely to be
a good deal for the investor
I was magnifying honda Subhan when we
began there wasn't another ship like
this one we looked at what was on the
market and what kind of ideas there were
but we had to develop a lot on our own
using our own know how I use the home of
wine during the new owners will take on
the current 120 workers and they plan to
increase the workforce to 400 in the
next two years the focus will be on
vessels smaller than the Aeolus but that
doesn't bother anybody here see that
funny Anna off from CHS was never an
offshore shipyard CHS used to be a
shipyard that built excellent container
ships and then it tried to find its way
to producing specialized ships but it
failed because of high costs and yet and
now it has a workforce that is capable
of building all kinds of ships alysha
football for now there's reason to
celebrate Oliver Arnold is also pleased
with the ALS the shipyard took it to the
limit in every aspect now there are
hopes of comer scenes ahead